peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci du fond du coeur d'être
fidèle à notre télé magouilles quotidien
comme il se doit
je remercie surtout isabelle presque
adam l'accueillir aujourd'hui cette
famille le jeu de la séduction c'est
pour plus tard
alors nous avons commencé tout de suite
pense à voir qui parmi vous a le numéro
le numéro qui a été choisi par notre
huissier maître en foire aux grandes
familles huissier c'est le numéro 27 qui
est sélectionné s'il vous plaît peut-il
se manifester
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit de ma vie a ajouté je viens
d'ouvrir un cabinet de voyants
exorcistes marabout et que si ta femme
disparaît je la fais revenir dans les 46
heures chrono plus vite que la redoute
bon voilà je suppose que comme tout le
monde vous allez à auby un passe temps
j'aime le sport tas de gens voudraient
avec ma femme en fait nous voulons de
l'eau dans la casse
raza aussi tu très bien voilà raconte
vous restez derrière votre mamadou je
regarde le deuxième numéro toujours
tirent au hasard bien sûr il s'agit du
numéro 432 432 s'il vous plaît c'est le
4 le 3 et 2 2 oui
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit donc de deux chroniques de
riddick bonjour qu'est ce que vous
faites
je m'appelle à véronique j'ai 26 ans je
suis que c'est grâce à l'exploiter je
comptais pas faire ça toute ma vie je
compte bientôt un peu question alors on
va placer encore si danger parce que
vous avez un hobby un passe temps bien
sûr mais bien sûr bach mozart alors vous
restez tous les deux dans votre revue
l'histoire on oublie pas qu avec cat et
les magouilles ont dans la formule 1 on
commence tout de suite les premières
questions qui attendent et je préfère
poser la question d'abord vous répondez
ensuite c'est plus simple pour moi
ben oui c'est plus le jeu va les écouter
bien question rapidité 1 qui a écrit les
fables de la fontaine
bravo qui a écrit les lettres de mon
moulin mon moulin mais en question sur
le sport non non c'est pas ça
question sur le tennis qui a perdu tous
nos rapports
[Applaudissements]
c'est facile oui alors maintenant une
question d'ethnologie quel est l'animal
poilus qui se rapproche le plus de
l'homme dennis ross
si oui un petit peu une grande nerveuse
aujourd'hui à littérature qui a écrit
les misérables qui a écrit les
misérables bon qui a écrit la valise en
carton 8 allée sombre elle a pas de
réponse on les a pris très fort bon
maintenant pour les questions
individuelles je m'approche de mamadou
bâ mamadou à la pêche ou la banane
ah ben si je gagne ce soir le golo alors
je vous donne des noms de personnalités
mamadou et vous me dites si son blanc ou
noir s'est fâché c'est facile mais le
bras puis l'avoir écouté bien michel
blanc blanc bravo et réglant mois michel
noir plein temps soyez un piège michael
jackson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo mme haman où vous en êtes bien
ceinture alors maintenant si oui c'était
facile bien sûr verdict alors maintenant
on va faire plus facile avec vous on va
faire le jeu 2 2 le jeu du couple alors
je vous donne la première moitié d'un
couple et vous me donnez l'autre moitié
d'accord vous avez compris quelques
questions non c'est simple je vous dis
par exemple laurel et ben vous me
répondez hardy voilà bah oui c'est ça
alors écoutez bien romeo et non pourquoi
même année de non j'ai pas dit john
boehner
non véronique s'est pas dites de dj dee
laurel et hardy est un exemple mais là
c'est roméo et juliette juliette
ah bah oui allez on y va à jacques
dutronc et françoise juillet mais non
ordi j'ai fait j'ai dit que mes que t'es
pas mettre celui-ci tonia oui d'accord
mais ces données les bombes est d'accord
me suis dit voilà mais j'ai pas du tout
tous croient pas s'énerver c'est qu'un
jeu ce que je m'énerve mois ont continué
les magouilles au mandat les fouilles
questions sur la révolution française
qui a été assassiné dans sa baignoire
non non non enfin mamadou non non c'est
facile ça borbet citez-moi de
révolutionnaires français à 6 à
robespierre et jean marc thibault
messieurs vous pas de la révolution et
coco décapiter les nomme stovall
voilà là là là on change de sujet on
oublie sport sport quelle est la
première ville arabe traversée par le
paris dakar marché des hôtels et le
prénom de miu miu miu
bon alors écoutez écoutez mamadou ouais
ouais ouais vous êtes avec votre femme
au l'angola cet arrêt automatique
ouais 7 avec votre femme et ses comptes
avec la machine à laver vous appelez
dans ce cas-là d'arte et voilà qu'à
trouver le vaccin contre la rage rika
zaraï où je veux une bonne réponse
mamadou leur site et moi trois hommes
sales français mais n'importe lesquels
tigana giresse et platini la lassitude
une réponse dans l'artois j'aurais
préféré ugo robin depuis six ans mais
oui d'accord mais voit les remplaçants
je les connais pas
c'est par un petit enfant
[Musique]
merci pour eux vous est propre aimable
aujourd'hui sont gratinés alors
maintenant nous allons savoir qui va
gagner le gros lot john ça m'a échappé
[Applaudissements]
ouais on va se c'est sa bombe à savoir 1
voilà maintenant on va savoir donc qui
va gagner qui va gagner le nom de ce
grand loup alors on peut écouter c'est
très facile pour gouverner écoutez c'est
une question très facile qui a séjourné
mais non j'ai pas aux agressions d'abord
retourner ensuite 1 écoutez bien qui a
chanté comme un ouragan elle est libérée
vous pour éviter la question c'est une
princesse à l'ami de monaco
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]